5 de la tarde en long beach boulevard en
compton
es el final de una larga jornada para
muchos trabajadores el inicio de una
larga noche para las prostitutas
esta joven de rojo al parecer muy joven
es tan solo un cebo fue ubicada por la
policía es uno de nuestros agentes de
costumbre patrulla las calles en un
vehículo de la policía nos encontramos
en el corazón de una operación de la
unidad de lucha contra el tráfico de
personas de la policía de los ángeles
el objetivo es detener a los clientes de
la prostitución
el sargento walker quien no desea
mostrar su rostro supervisa la
infiltración el vehículo blanco
[Aplausos]
negocio abiertamente una relación sexual
a cambio de dinero acaba de girar en la
calle que cerramos lo detendrán
el sospechoso fue detenido en flagrancia
puede ponerle una multa de hasta 1200
dólares o imponerle un año de cárcel si
reincide
esta noche la policía detuvo a 23
personas en unas cuantas horas en
california es ilegal pagar por
relaciones sexuales
pero los esfuerzos de la policía de los
ángeles no se centran sólo en las calles
la verdadera amenaza se encuentra en
internet las páginas especializadas y
las redes sociales atraen a cada vez más
menores
nos reunimos con el sargento walker y
sus hombres en el marco de una ciber
operación en una habitación de motel
transformada en centro de comando aquí
los agentes de la policía se hacen pasar
por clientes de paso en búsqueda de
jóvenes prostitutas
tratamos de interceptar a menores lo que
llamamos niñas sexualmente explotadas
con fines comerciales entonces sí nos
parecen jóvenes en internet establecemos
una cita en la habitación y las
detenemos y con frecuencia vemos niñas
que comienzan cuando tienen entre 14 y
17 años y establecen varias citas
habitación 121 detrás de la puerta el
equipo está listo para intervenir
la joven dice tener 26 años pero no
tiene documento de identidad
dice estar de viaje a lo largo del país
con su esposo y querer ganar algo de
dinero
información imposible de verificar
si nos dicen que no son víctimas del
tráfico de personas
entonces aplicamos el procedimiento en
caso de infracción son conducidas a la
comisaría de nor walt tomamos sus
huellas digitales y les notificamos para
que comparezcan ante un juez dentro de
unos meses
y si son menores entonces se las
entregamos a los agentes de los
servicios sociales que esperan en la
habitación del lado
esta noche la unidad especial detiene
también a un presunto pedófilo que vino
a tener relaciones sexuales con un joven
de 16 años
un perfil en línea creado por los
policías
y ya
en español
a
este hombre podría ser condenado a 10
años de prisión
[Música]
en eeuu un menor es explotado en la
industria del sexo cada dos minutos
[Música]
cerca de 150.000 jóvenes son vendidos y
comprados para sexo cada año el 60% son
estadounidenses
[Música]
[Aplausos]
mayor y vendió su cuerpo durante más de
10 años
cuando uno está con un cliente puede
hacer lo que quiere
pagó por ello
una vez uno de ellos casi me mata
actualmente ayuda a víctimas del tráfico
sexual a salir adelante
la urgencia es encontrarles un techo
lejos de su proxeneta
anna quien desea permanecer en el
anonimato llegó a este motel hace una
semana
fui secuestrada por un proxeneta cuando
tenía 14 años en long beach california
era una adolescente con problemas me la
pasaba en la calle y me subí al vehículo
que no era no regresé a casa durante año
y medio
perdí la confianza en mí misma
era fácil permanecer encerrada en esta
situación le temía era mucho mayor
grande y fuerte
menos arriesgado que el tráfico de
drogas el negocio del sexo es muy
lucrativo cada prostituta le genera más
o menos 180.000 dólares al año a su
proxeneta
pero no
harman kim es un proxeneta arrepentido
ganaba 1200 dólares al día vendiendo el
cuerpo de mujeres en las calles de san
diego
quería ganar mucho dinero quería sacar a
mi familia ya mis amigos de la pobreza
habíamos sufrido mucho con ellos no
sabíamos cómo salir de ella pensé que el
tráfico de personas sería la solución a
sus 39 años y tras varios años en
prisión
armand acude a su vivencia para
sensibilizar a los jóvenes se necesita
prevención no esperemos a que cometan
una infracción para encarcelarlos si
creen y saben que pueden hacer las cosas
mejor entonces no elegirán el camino
incorrecto
en eeuu el tráfico de personas es la
actividad criminal más rentable después
de la droga
esta esclavitud moderna genera 32 mil
millones de dólares al año
[Música]
e